[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and my brother John answer your
questions give you dubious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon John how you
doing I'm doing well it's cold here so I
thought I would read a poem about spring
when it comes time for me to read my
poem but I don't want to talk too much
today how are you doing I'm good I'm
afraid if you don't want to talk too
much because that means that I'll have
to talk more which is scary for me and I
don't really know how to do it I know
how to talk the amount that I currently
talk and not more than that I feel like
not talking is easier than talking more
I could be wrong other than that I'm
doing well my my life is good I've got
friends staying in my house and and I
just got back from the east coast which
was a very weird and fun trip well Hank
I mentioned how much we talked because
we've just received an email from Peter
Dressel who with his sister Maggie have
put together a public report a
scientific article on the question of
who talks more in episodes of dear Hank
and John I'll just read you the abstract
it contains most of the relevant
information since Hank and John have had
several arguments about who talks more
in the podcast we figured we would re
this into the episodes and keep track
the results show that John indisputably
talks more yeah uh-huh I'm a little
surprised I always thought that I was
the you know the quiet really but
surprisingly intelligent one it turns
out that I'm the talkative stupid one uh
what were the what were the numbers what
does how does it break down basically
for every one minute that I am talking
you talk for 47 seconds I'm gonna put
the whole thing online you can you can
look at me a look at the Twitter Twitter
John Green I don't think that's actually
if you type in Twitter John Green into
Google I bet it'll find me um and you
can see the results for yourself it's an
extremely complicated and compelling
piece of work that Peter and Maggie put
together in their spare time so thank
thanks very much to these two students
at the University of Iowa both of whom
are clearly geniuses
well that it seems like it's a fair
amount of work to do and I appreciate
them doing it so that I can feel
validated and and under appreciated I'm
sure that everyone out there wishes that
they got just as much Hank as they got
John if not a little more well Hank
speaking of which would you like a short
poem for today let's do that I guess you
know you're gonna talk more cuz you do
the short poem oh yeah no they accounted
for that they said I still talk more
even without the short poem okay so
don't you worry
I'm the talkative one I'm gonna read you
an EE Cummings poem that if I can find
it in my my my-y Cummings poem book that
I've had since high school and it's got
it's essentially got all of the poems
dog-eared because you know at different
times in my life I've liked different
poems but this given the weather I
thought this one would be perfect oh
sweet spontaneous earth how often have
the doting fingers of Puri --nt
philosophers pinched and poked thee has
the naughty thumb of science prodded thy
beauty how often have religions taken
the upon their scraggy knees squeezing
and buffeting thee that thou mightest
conceive gods but true to the
incomparable couch of death by rhythmic
lover thou answerest them only with
spring hmm
the E Cummings poem often known as oh
sweet spontaneous as that is its first
line but yes sweet spontaneous life that
only gives us spring we want more but
spring is what we get in this world Hank
not however for several months if the
weather outside in Indianapolis is any
indication I would imagine not also if
just the the way that the months work is
in the indication I mean it's gonna be a
while I I take a little bit of issue
with the fact that science is prodded or
the earth with its thumb and and
Cummings thinks that we have only found
spring when in fact we have found a
great deal many useful things oh you've
got to give a cummings a little bit of
poetic license Hank that's all I can say
well what is I yeah what does he mean I
think it means that that you know
scientists prod earth and you know they
may discover me
anything's but the beaut that they don't
the beauty I don't I don't know I don't
know that I agree with that part of the
poem actually can we move on to
questions from our listeners
maybe the true the true the true gift
that the earth gives we're just finding
things of things out about the earth but
the thing that it will give us is the
spring whether we like it or not spring
is coming
but first winter is coming bring us
that's the the sequel this equal to the
the Song of Ice and Fire
yes spring is the last book will be
called spring is coming exclamation
point and it'll just be full of
happiness and joy and the mother of
dragons will live happily with King
Joffrey and everything will work out one
day oh gosh they should just they should
just be kids and make out in cars like
in my books no I tried to make those
movies they aren't quite as popular
let's answer some questions from
listeners all right this one is from
anonymous who has a question about
making out and asks dear Hank and John
is it always a bad idea to make out with
one's roommate no the roommate in
question asked me out a few years before
we were sharing a flat and I turned him
down I don't know if it's availability
getting to know him better or just
knowing that some attraction was there
at some point on his part but now I feel
attracted to him and I'd love some of
your dubious advice I mean I believe in
making out with people who want to make
out with you and who you want to make
out with yes I have a pretty
straightforward set of beliefs around
this called enthusiastic consent yes I
think also that it is it is not a bad
idea to make out with one of your
roommates if they are into that and you
are in fact it sounds exciting and fun
and I I see that there could potentially
be down the road problems with this I
you know and that is oh yeah there were
there were almost search and that that
is up sorry I just cut you off I'm sorry
I'm the brother who talks yes you will
heart and I will say that that is also
true of everything you ever do in life
yeah they're always gonna be problems
down the road that's a problem for
future you I don't think you're setting
future you up for a necessary definitive
disaster just by making out with your
roommate I mean you might be increasing
the chances that future you is going to
have a problem but a
if you try to minimize the chances that
future you will ever experience any kind
of misery it's gonna be very difficult
for current you to have any joy yes yes
it will be very difficult for current
YouTube do anything outside of the just
like a Walden center block 4x4 room
oh that sounds very depressing why does
the room have to be so small it's meters
four by four meters just oh okay so
that's lovely all right let's move on
Hank this question is from Matt who
writes dear John and Hank I'm going to
propose to my girlfriend in the coming
months and would like to buy her an
engagement ring the problem is that
buying a customary diamond ring isn't
something I'm willing to do unless I can
feel confident the stories conflict-free
is that even possible I know the
Kimberley process is supposed to combat
this but is it really working I did not
do any research on this John so I have
no idea but I'll say what I did for
Catherine which was give I gave her an
old ring that had been and had been
owned by a dead relative and that was
like well even if this was a conflict
diamond when it was mined eighty years
ago it is now what just going to get
thrown away like I'm not sure what else
to do with it right I'm a big believer
in recycling rings whether it's an
estate piece that you get from somebody
else or from a jeweler or it's something
from someone in your family I am also a
big believer and I know that this is not
particularly old fashioned of me but I'm
a big believer in having like open and
honest conversations in the run-up to an
engagement about engagement like I know
that there's something wonderful about
being surprised and everything but I
feel like it it puts a lot of pressure
on these old-fashioned gender roles to
have you know one person spend like many
months discerning whether or not they
want to marry the other person and the
other person have to answer a yes-or-no
question in like five seconds mm-hmm
agree so I would say maybe include your
partner in this conversation about the
engagement ring that's maybe a way to
also include your partner in this
conversation about just
learning whether or not it is a good
idea to spend the rest of your natural
lives together indeed indeed and also
you know that you share values and maybe
she doesn't even like diamonds this is a
thing that happens and maybe she wants
the Sapphire which you know you also
then have to figure out whether it's a
conflict-free sapphire but a lot of
sapphires are mined in America actually
right here in Montana which is why I
know a fair bit about sapphires I yes
John that is a great point and I I think
that the number one thing to know is
that this doesn't have to be something
that is a secret and in fact it was not
really a secret in either John or eyes
case it was kind of a surprise when it
actually happened but you know yeah it
didn't I didn't feel comfortable
springing that kind of thing on someone
I loved out of nowhere
unless I knew for sure that she was
gonna say yes so we talked about but you
can still have a little bit of a
surprise right I mean you can have some
timing surprise that's that's what we
did yeah yeah our engagement was
actually a complete disaster but I think
the real the real surprise here Hank is
that you are a sapphire miner that is
not something that I knew about you well
I have mined sapphires actually how long
have you been mining sapphires tell me
more I I have done that thing where you
go out to the place where they have gems
in the ground and they give you a bucket
of dirt and then you like mooning
through the sluice and like shake a box
around until you see which which rocks
look particularly pleasant and I found
that garnet that way once I didn't find
a sapphire but there are places in
Montana we can go and find sapphires and
then if you find a good enough one you
can actually have it cut for more than
the price of buying one at a store and
then and then you can have that one be
the one that you mount in a ring and
that way it's like you were you were
that you were indeed the miner of the
thing though most of the hard work got
done before you got there of digging the
dirt out of the hill but it's very
interesting to me that that is where
gemstones come from just just dirt here
in Montana what I talk more than you
let's move on to another question this
question is from CJ who asks Dear John
and Hank after having gone to countless
sporting events movie shows and other
events as such I still cannot figure one
which armrest is mine all right well
this is a very very important addition
and Hank happens to be one of the
world's leading experts in armrest
etiquette okay if there are three seats
particularly if you are on a plane if
you are on one of the outside seats you
get one armrest the armrest that is
clearly yours that no one else can have
access to the person in the middle gets
both armrests s' to themselves this is
the only equitable way to do it it is
the only thing that makes sense because
the person in the middle has nowhere to
go
that is correct they are clearly clearly
in the disadvantaged place and should be
treated as such unless there is some
other extenuating circumstance happening
and that that infuriates me when I have
a person next to me who is clearly it
like just a person and is taking up my
armrest when I'm in the middle and just
and like is intentionally doing it I see
them like like as if it is some kind of
weird power play that they need to win
this this interaction and come out on
top and have both arm rests to
themselves when they already have the
aisle seat there are two kinds of people
in this world yes there are people who
honor the fact that when all things are
equal the person in the middle seat
should have both arm rests access to
both armrests regardless of whether they
are using them at any given time they
must have access to both arm rests and
then there are monsters those are the
two kinds of people in the world now
Adam at a movie theater unless you are
on an aisle it is gonna be a toss-up
it's basically gonna say like you get
one unless you're on the aisle will you
obviously get the aisle armrest and not
the one on the interior of the seat the
it's just if you're in the middle then
you take whichever one is available to
you if you are having that problem where
two people have ended up just do two
stochasticity and and you know like
there's just going to be a person who
maybe ends up with neither armrests
and you don't know either person on
either side well enough to ask them or
like nudge them out of the way then you
are just going to have a less enjoyable
movie-going experience than you would
have otherwise had we're going to have
to live with that
I don't agree no I don't agree at all I
think there is a way for everyone to
have one armrest there is but it
requires communication and that is no it
doesn't require communication it
requires a basic understanding of the
rules of etiquette where when you are
seated at a formal dinner is your water
versus the other person's water your
water my water is on like the right hand
side that is on the right hand side your
water is on the right hand side ergo if
you are on the isle the right hand side
Isle where your right hand is on the
Isle armrest that is where you put your
drink and then everyone has their right
handed armrest to put their arm on and
no one has their left-handed armrest to
put their arm on except for the person
who is on the other aisle who is allowed
to use both of their arm rests okay I
see I see that this works the only way
for this to actually function though is
if people accept this as a rule of movie
theaters which i think is going to be a
very difficult thing to get into the
popular culture I think we have done a
good job starting that strongly disagree
Hank our podcast has a massive reach
among moviegoers it already has done we
did it use your right arm rest and put
your drink in your right arm rest rink
holder and everything is gonna be fine
and if somebody doesn't do that just not
rudely not like don't make a big deal of
it like we do with the the toilet paper
over the toilet paper under issue not
just be like if you don't mind there is
an established etiquette for these
things it was established by Hank and
John Green on a podcast in 2015 if you
could just use the right hand side
because that is the side you have access
to your right arm rest I mean obviously
if you have a broken arm or something if
there's you know disabilities involved
that changes everything but all
things being equal right armrest is
yours at the movie theater west arm left
arm rest is your next-door neighbor's
figured out I think it is now time for
another question and this one's from
Vicki who asks dear Hank and John help
there's a wasp trapped in my dorm room
and I am allergic he's been here a while
and we've bonded so I've named him I
have a sliding glass window which I
usually leave open to the screen to
allow air flow otherwise it gets too hot
and stifled in the room it is very
important to note that there are no
holes in the screen I have now trapped
mr. wasp between the screen and the
glass window what do I do because there
is no way for him to get out also is
there a way to stun a wasp without
killing it and or getting stung my mr.
wasp and I want the same thing for him
to not be in my room so I don't feel
comfortable with killing him on a moral
level because he probably wandered into
my room by accident help um okay so I'm
gonna level with you here this is gonna
be difficult I hope that you're seated
presumably a week and a half later
everything is just as it was the MA the
wasp is still alive still stuck between
screen and window you're gonna have to
kill the wasp completely disagree or or
you're gonna have to let the wasp die
which I suspect may be what has happened
in the intervening 10 days because we
failed to get to your question in time
ultimately it is not your fault that mr.
wasp died it is entirely our fault right
right there are two there are multiple
reasons why mr. wasp died mr. wasp died
because of us he died because of you and
he died because death is inevitable and
and mr. mr. wasp was going to die no
matter what and possibly just just
through the act of wandering into your
room it disrupted his his potential
lifestyle and his eating habits enough
that he was bound to die if mr. wasp is
still alive by some miracle just get a
person who is not allergic to wasps and
who is feeling you know brave and
chivalrous to help you out and be the
person who puts the cup over
to wasp and then slides a piece of paper
under the cup and then takes that
outside and I think but but however I
think that if you did kill miss mr. wasp
whether by just leaving it there or just
being you know tired of it and so you
got some wasp spray and and went outside
and no gave it a little bit of a you
know a jolt I think that that's okay I
think that mr. mister wasp you know was
going to have to die and and you know it
was going to be a sad a death full of
suffering no matter what and Hank it's
okay
having now celebrated the life of mr.
wasp I think it's time for us to move on
to a new question this one is from our
father Mike Greene who writes Dear John
and Hank it drives me crazy each week
when I hear Hank start the podcast with
quote where me and my brother John
provide dubious advice and news one time
Hank said where my brother and I and it
was music to my ears I thought it was
the beginning of a trend but apparently
I was wrong
me and my friend seems to be more and
more common versus my friend and I what
is the official position of English
grammar enforcers on this important
matter love dad well dad I will tell you
as your favorite son that you are
correct that Hank should not be saying
me and my brother John at least from a
strict grammar enforcement perspective
he should be saying my brother John and
I however you are also and this pains me
to say it incorrect because grammar
exists who make language as clear as
possible there is no other reason why
grammar exists it exists to make
language as transparent as possible so
that when we are talking to each other
we are never confused
we are never we are never put in a we
are never put by language in in in a
place of needless ambiguity and me and
my brother John is as clear I think to
the contemporary listener as my brother
John and I in fact like the what the me
is not going to be confusing to any
wallet does is trigger something inside
of us that says whoa boy that's
steak but if we can put that aside and
learn to live with it which I think we
have to it does not introduce any lack
of clarity into the sentence and
therefore I must reluctantly say that my
brother
well technically grammatically incorrect
is not doing something that I think we
need to change all right it's really
shocking to me having heard that but you
talk more than I do on this podcast
because boy you really got to the point
fast who did dot did not you didn't
wander around at all you didn't you know
didn't it didn't take you any time at
all to figure out but I will in addition
to that say that I think I'm providing
necessary clarity by saying me and my
brother John because the name of the
podcast is dear Hank and John which it
is because of the nature of the universe
and I want to make sure that people know
that me is Hank and that I am the first
thing and John is John he is the second
thing and that's that as important I
think I hate to make you backup but did
you just say that the name of our
podcast is dear Hank and John because
that is the nature of the universe yes
that's why it's called dear Hank and
John it is part of the it's part of the
nature of the universe that's why I come
first in the in the name of the podcast
because of the nature of the universe
and so I want to make sure that
everybody knows that when you write to
us you should be asking dear Hank and
John and the email address is Hank and
John at gmail.com you know it all has to
sort of fall into place well but I came
I came first though in the sense that
you know I literally was born first its
Dear John and Hank our parents have two
children John their firstborn child who
presumably would inherit the throne were
they royalty and Hank their second born
child who from what I can tell via
Prince Harry is the one who parties a
lot yeah but that is absolutely the case
that does not change the fact that due
to the nature of the universe the
podcast is called dear Hank and John the
email addresses Hank and John and when I
say me and my brother John it is because
Hank comes first when in relation to
things regarding the podcast right but
in relation to things regarding like
life and overall privilege and
superiority and what
that's that would be me first John John
and Hank dear Johnny I think that it's
important that that Hank and John Green
look that way Hank and John Green for a
number for a number of reasons one being
the nature of the universe and two being
a search engine optimization because
people are more likely to Google John
Green than Hank green due to you being
alive long enough to have had
considerably more success than me that
is actually the most compelling Pro Hank
and John argument I have ever heard over
John and Hank you know exactly where to
hit me to get what you want Hank which
is to hit me in my narcissism button
well your search engine optimization
button anyway I just want to say John
this podcast is brought to you by
needless sibling bickering needless
sibling bickering it's a it's apparently
hopefully enjoyable to people who are
not us today's podcast is also brought
to you by failing to get to the point
dancing around the point a John Green
strategy for finding ways to talk longer
than his brother since nineteen eighty
this podcast is additionally brought to
you by mister wasp mister wasp very
difficult to say and almost certainly
day and lastly this podcast is actually
brought to you by you our listeners we
have just started a patreon campaign for
dear Hank and John so if you head on
over to patreon slash dear Hank
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John you
can become a patron of this podcast and
support it directly we're going to be
doing monthly hangouts where we'll
answer your questions alive and talk to
you about stuff that interests us right
before we record the podcast or possibly
right after depending on what's going on
that week we're doing this instead of a
traditional sponsorship package with a
sponsor I know lots of that's what most
podcasts do but we're doing this because
well mostly because we we like it better
we like the idea of working for you
better than the idea of working for
large corporation and also because we
feel like it's good to have multiple
stakeholders instead of just like the
one or two advertising sponsors that we
have so that's what we're doing with
dear Hank and John of course you don't
have to become a patron it's ok if you
don't the podcast will not change for
you in any way
it's just that hopefully the podcast
will maybe become a little bit better a
little little bit richer for those of
you who do become patrons over at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John did
I ramble on too much Hank uh you know
you did it you did it you did the thing
I I felt for a moment that maybe it
would be better if like we traded off
things like you talked for a little bit
about one thing and I talked for a
little bit about one thing and then we
like sounded like we were really in it
together and excited about it which we
are and we are but it was yeah you
totally did it and I don't and like we
didn't prepare that in any way so of
course it would be very difficult to
have actually done done that and I think
you did honestly as a brother a
fantastic job and I'm proud of you
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John or
Dear John and Hank that won't take you
to the right patreon page but it's just
a fun thing to type ok let's do another
question this one's from Kristen who
asks dear Hank and John opinions on this
world war 3 business is their world war
3 business I hadn't heard about the
world war 3 business John the Pope says
that we are in a kind of World War 3 and
several other people have said I don't
know what do you think Hank ah well I
look at World War 1 in World War 2 and I
think about those and I feel like
calling this world war 3 is is kind of
kind of a dishonouring the memory of
those events which were which were
horrific beyond anything humans have
ever experienced like we got to remember
how bad those things were and if you
think this is anything like how bad that
was then then then we did not do a good
job teaching you history in our in your
school system yeah I mean I'm so I'm
mostly inclined to agree with you I
actually think there was sort of a world
war before World War one around you know
between like 1846 and 1848 but the only
reason that I think that we should start
to worry that this looks
little bit like world war three is that
the whole world is increasingly drawn up
in it
and that you know these these failed
states in Libya and Syria and in a
couple of other countries are are of
should be of grave concern also also the
failed state in Somalia and you know we
need we need to these places need
governments and the longer they go
without governments the more dangerous
it becomes not just regionally but to
the whole world but I agree I don't
think that we're in a world war three
and I don't think that that is a is a
helpful way to describe this conflict at
all because there's plenty of
exaggerating going on right there's
plenty of hyperbole there's lots of
people trying to turn this into a
civilizational conflict which it's just
not and I don't want to be part of that
because I think history will remember
those people as having been very very
bad yes is that fair to say is that is
fair to say I just want to say that
during World War two three percent of
the world's population died if that
happened now if three percent of the
world's population died right now it
would be around two hundred million
people which is just old awful lot yes
let us hope that that this does not
become World War three I strongly doubt
that it will by the way I think we have
lots of things that keep that from
happening
the amazing thing though is that the
world lost three percent of its
populations like like imagining that if
we today had a war in which 200 million
people died which is two-thirds of the
population of the u.s. of course they
would be distributed all across the
world that we could then go on and not
have that be something that destroyed
earth something that destroyed humanity
we could go on and and you know and then
have you know 60 years of relative
prosperity which is what we have now had
after World War two or 70 years
that is remarkable and I'm proud of it
good on that generation for coming out
of that and doing great things and and
building a pretty great world for their
grandchildren and great-grandchildren
who I am among yeah we just got to take
care of a lot of the carbon emissions
that they created in that process and we
should be fine which yeah I mean frankly
I understand that we have been passed
down negative impacts due to all of the
fantastic things those people did and
you know like like looking at that and
saying they only did these nasty things
to us when in fact they did lots of
lovely things and now when they were
kids
refrigerators were luxury items and now
everyone has one and isn't that lovely
that I can have like that that everyone
in America has you know running hot
water and plumbing and like these are
things that that and and that all people
can vote who are over 18 and that and
that you know everyone like in most in
many states everyone who loves each
other can get married which was not a
thing and and you know we we have an
integrated society yeah yeah I think
you're absolutely right in to me when
you look at American history you see a
slow but fairly consistent march toward
more people having more rights I mean
this country started out with very very
few people being able to vote in our
supposed democracy and these days you
know there are many more people much
larger percentage of the American
population can really participate in the
democracy so while there's much to be
concerned about I also think there's
much to be hopeful about I agree John I
have a question that from Maggie subject
one of this is I finally know who I am
thanks BuzzFeed which i think is the the
title of an article that Maggie should
write she says dear Hank and John what
are your thoughts on our cultural
fascination with self-definition via
online quizzes personality inventories
and other such means of Pigeon holding
ourselves even if it's ostensibly just
for fun and she asks as like sort of
like deeper more interesting bits of
this but I just want to sort of leave it
at that because it's just such a big
question I want to make a series of
videos on it I do
find it fascinating how we search out
identity and we try to figure out who we
are and it is so difficult for us to do
that to know our own self that we go to
BuzzFeed and as she says I still find
myself wanting to know if I'm pumpkin
spice or peppermint mocha yeah I mean I
don't think it's particularly new you
know when I was a child I remember
taking those quizzes in ym magazine or
in Seventeen magazine and they were the
exact same quizzes that we're trying to
do the exact same things like you know
try to help me understand who I am you
know through these silly quizzes I also
used to take them in Cosmopolitan
magazine which one of our mom's friends
subscribed to and like they had a lot of
sex tips so it was the closest that I
you know the closest thing that I had to
like what women think about sex which in
retrospect not particularly useful
Cosmopolitan magazine but I would take
those quizzes and even though they were
for like adult women in their early 30s
trying to figure out like what kind of
man they wanted I would be like I wonder
what kind of man I want and and I found
them like tremendously helpful and
interesting so I I find I don't want to
like I I find it hard to criticize those
quizzes because I think that like trying
to figure out who you are whether it's a
pumpkin spice latte or your myers-briggs
type whatever it is like all of that
stuff is part of a process of like
trying to understand yourself in this
context of knowing that there are six
billion other humans out there who are
just as human as you I like the fact
that there are six billion other humans
because apparently you are 1 billion
humans are there 7 billion humans sorry
there's yeah there there are more than 7
billion humans we just keep making them
yeah we do it's the one thing we're real
good at it's very interesting to me that
we know how many people there are on
earth it's such a difficult logistical
problem to have been able to overcome
but anyway my answer is is roughly the
same the only thing that I will say to
people who are trying to define
themselves whether based on quizzes or
based on you know like sort of the the
types that we that we assign whether
that's introvert or extrovert or you
know
all the myers-briggs types I'd say that
in my life I have I have changed myself
many times and I have found that Who I
am
relates much more to who I think I am
than to Who I am and my you know I find
it not difficult and I don't know if I'm
unique or if I'm like unusual in this
but I find it not difficult to be
different from me one day one day later
you know and and certainly one year or
ten years later and I I'm very glad that
I am not stuck in one self and and I am
constantly excited to be to be a
different person sometimes and to try
different things and to and to not do
things that I feel like that that's not
a thing that Hank green would do that
does not seem like a Hank green thing
and then to do that thing and to be like
well you know maybe Hank green isn't who
I thought he was and to not be
constrained by the our perception of
ourselves oh my god it's burning that's
trying to help you out yep
I don't I'm not cooking anything right
now but I'm sure someone is check the
oven you guys is your burner still on
does your dog need a wok don't get too
caught up into your Hank and John are
you waiting at the gate at the airport
and maybe have forgotten that you in
fact need to get on the airplane go now
okay we have a very important question
from Talia this is one that only you can
answer it's really in your whale I was
gonna say wheelhouse but for some reason
it came out whale house this one is
really really in your whale house Hank
it is right where your whales live how
did you know about my whale house that
was supposed to be a secret all right
Hank this questions from Talia are
hotdogs sandwiches
well you know John a the fact that you
are asking this question makes me think
that you don't do not listen to enough
podcasts this is one of the legendary
questions of the judge John Hodgman
podcast where where he goes into deeply
into whether hot dogs or sandwiches in
his conclusion John hodgman's conclusion
and I am absolutely enthusiastic to
adopt his stance on this is that
dogs are not sandwiches and why they are
not sandwiches frankly I don't care that
much because John Hodgman said they are
not if you would like to hear his
reasoning
you can go listening to that you can go
listen to that episode of the judge John
Hodgman podcast which is a lovely
wonderful podcast that I would say is is
about 10% funnier than dear Hank and
John but they do not talk about death as
much as we do so we have that on begging
of which Hank it is time to get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon would
would you like to begin this week with
the news from Mars or should we go
straight to AFC Wimbledon let's go to
AFC Wimbledon first so I can finish out
the news for once okay so Hank let me
ask you to do a thought experiment and
also everyone listening right now
obviously don't close your eyes if
you're driving or whatever but close
your eyes Hank you close your eyes close
your eyes if you're in a place where you
safely can and what do you see when you
close your eyes like little green
sparkles okay now I want you to imagine
that you are deep inside the world's
deepest cave which as I recall is in
Vietnam you're deep you're 5,000 feet
down in the world's deepest cave and
you've got your eyes closed
you've got your lamp off you are in what
is called cave darkness and I want you
to open your eyes right now deep inside
that cave tell me what you see I see
nothing and it is it is so intensely
nothing that it feels like a sensation
on the back of my eyes Hank right now
you are in the very same darkness that
AFC Wimbledon is in yesterday as I am
recording this podcast last week as you
are listening to it AFC Wimbledon lost
to dag and red dag and red who were in
the relegation zone in 23rd place oh
they lost to dag and red at home at
Kings meadow one nil and an 80 80th
minute goal from a goalkeeper mistake
resulted in a dag and red goal and I
mean this is not just the kind of game
that we can't lose it's the kind of game
that we can't tie now
despite and and the game before that was
it was a draw
and despite these recent disappointments
and the cave darkness that surrounds us
we remain in 11th place just three
points out of sixth and sixth is it
would be high enough to go to the
playoffs to get at least have a chance
to get promoted up to Ligue 1 however
that that result is very worrisome the
fact that we couldn't score a goal
against Dagon red the fact that we
couldn't keep a clean sheet against
Dagon read both of these things very
very worrisome however wonderful news if
you are a dag or a red as you are now
out of the relegation zone putting York
City and Yeovil Town down there in the
bottom two that would go down B they
would be demoted out of the the Football
League entirely into the conference and
when you are demoted out of the football
we get it can and often does mean that
you cease to be a full-time professional
team so of course nobody wants that
but AFC Wimbledon still in eleventh
despite - not good results 19 games in -
a 46 game season we are in 11 well it
doesn't hurt more to lose to those teams
it just it's the same number of points
lost or not gained or whatever it's not
like that you lose to a really bad team
and you lose more points somehow that's
true it's just much harder to win
against the very good teams so you would
like to win against the bad teams right
so you you should you should be winning
yes if you're gonna be you're gonna be
playing bad teams you really got to
score those points when you can I guess
that makes them right because we still
have a lot of games against the teams at
the top at the table the likes of
Plymouth and Oxford and Accrington
Stanley that's too bad that's too bad
alright well in Mars news we have it's
always so hard to pick the Mars news but
but this year I'm this year this day I'm
going to tell you that Buzz Aldrin was
recently giving a speech and he let
loose some news that John F Kennedy when
talking to people about about the next
step in the space race wanted that next
step instead of
going to the moon to be going to Mars
and he went to MIT and he talked to a
bunch of smart people and he said I want
you to tell me whether or not we can go
to Mars like I want you to tell me how
we can get Americans on the surface of
Mars in the next you know like short
term like 15 months or something you
know not not 15 months fast
would we have to leave in like a week
yeah yes sooner than that that's
negative time so he went to those
engineers and they have he asked them to
figure it out and they came back to the
President of the United States John F
Kennedy and said no we can't do that
it is according to Buzz Aldrin they said
it's just a little too far to go which
is an interesting thing like you know
the reason why Mars is where Mars is has
a little bit to do with how the solar
system was formed but also a little bit
to do with randomness and Mars could be
closer it could be you know earth could
be smaller there could be a number of
different things that would make it a
lot easier to get to Mars but they are
not that way and so the reason we can't
get to Mars has a lot to do with just
the randomness of how the solar system
formed or that we haven't gotten to Mars
yet not that we can't get to Mars of
course we can and we will but in 1969
yeah John F Kennedy wanted to go to Mars
and and a bunch of smart people told him
instead that the moon the moon was a
more realistic goal and we should go for
that and of course we were able to
accomplish that and that as fantastic
and wonderful you said 1959 right
I said 69 well John F Kennedy had been
deceased for some time in 1969 sorry
that is when they wanted to get there ah
that seems more reasonable suddenly
suddenly I felt that I had glimpsed
perhaps the greatest conspiracy in
American history and Hank had uncovered
it yeah sorry about that thanks for
being the history buff who knows things
like when presidents died that's ok
thanks for being a guy who knows how to
spell Hygienist well I can I can be that
person for you John Thanks
so Hank what did we learn today we
learned that if you
want to make out with your roommate and
your roommate wants to make out with you
then that is the thing that you should
just do well at least in the opinion of
two people who give extremely dubious
advice yeah indeed exactly we also
learned that the earth could be smaller
or Mars could be closer but it isn't and
it isn't this is not something that you
learned that things could be I mean I
kind of learned it's never occurred to
me that the earth could be smaller yeah
it's very interesting to that like it
could be like that that you know like
the way that stuff got distributed that
that Mars would have been bigger than
Earth like that's it's very it's very
interesting
Mars is weird Mars is weird it's super
interesting John anyway sorry I get
excited about things and I cannot
articulate why and so I say things like
Mars is weird
and I've I smile widely while saying it
but it doesn't make a lot of sense how
is it that I talked more than you on
this podcast well I'm trying to make it
even that's doing my best to talk more
we'll see we'll see people are gonna
have to tell us if I caught up with you
or indeed surpassed you in this week's
podcast but we also learned that that
the proposal of marriage is not
necessarily something that should be a
surprise in fact it maybe is something
that should be talked about a little bit
before a thing that happens and we
learned that best what nothing I was
gonna say especially if you do at a
sports game or something just don't do
that don't not with all those people
staring and of course we learned that if
you are in the middle seat both arm
rests are yours by law and by right and
that if you were in a movie theater we
are instituting a policy where everybody
all things being equal gets the right
hand armrest except for the person on
the left hand side who gets two arm
rests congratulations person on the left
aisle we're gonna in 2045 we're gonna go
into a movie theater and and the first
seat that will be taken and every movie
theater in America will be down the left
hand side
and that will be media oh I hope it ends
up on my tombstone Hank in the meantime
I hope that everyone had a Happy
Thanksgiving including you Hank I wish
that we were spending it together but
instead we are spending it too part you
can email us your questions at Hank and
John at gmail.com you can also ask us
questions on the Twitter's hashtag dear
Hank and John you can follow us on
Twitter I'm at John Green Hank is at
Hank green again our patreon if you want
to support this podcast you can do so
via patreon a voluntary subscription
service there's some good perks
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
it's very important to Hank that you
know his snapchat it's Hank my snapchat
is Hank GRE thank John and yeah I I
think that you're missing out that's all
I'm saying is I think you're missing out
if you're not following me on snapchat
I'm not saying that like boy I want so
much snapchat followers there's nothing
that I want more than that it's like
it's something that I'm doing for you
people of the listening um speaking of
which Hank can you share with them that
I also have a snapchat yeah but you
don't use it I use it sometimes I never
see your story I don't know maybe I
don't look enough well no just tell them
what my snapchat is it's fine if
snapchat is John Green snaps how did you
know that I'm probably thought you
wouldn't know yes I just think it just
occurred to me that it couldn't be John
Green and then I was like but it's John
Green something and then I remember it's
John Green Stef's
which also I learned why after coming up
with the username is John Green's snaps
[Laughter]
all right well this has been the longest
outro we've ever recorded but thanks
again for listening
this podcast was edited by Nick Jenkins
the theme music is from gunnarolla and
as they say in our hometown don't forget
to be awesome
[Music]